はい 今日のテーマに入ります
なぜお釈迦様が出家されたのですかと
そういう背景があって
お釈迦様がなんで出家したのかということを考えなくちゃいけないんです
苦しみの悪循環を破り
究極の幸福を目指す道です
ブッダにとっては 今まで喋ったことには全く関係ないんです
全くも関係ないんです
お釈迦様はものすごい若い時
出家したんです 何か道を発見したかったんです
シッダールタ王子の粗を探してという
あのシッダールタ王子というのはお釈迦様のことです
お釈迦様の名前です 知識人は出家は負け犬の道であるという前提で
学問的にシッダールタゴータマ王子の生活を調べてみるんです
ちょっとあの仏教学者が書いている本をちょこちょこと調べると
ブッダの生涯と書いているところでは
なぜシッダールタ王子が出家したのかという問題に触れます
しかし その人々が今まで説明した
あの出家するのは負け犬だという
あの立場で調べるんです
シッダールタ王子もどうせ負け犬でしょう
我々みたいな立派な社会人でいられなかったでしょうという態度なんです
だから シッダールタ王子の粗を探すんです
何の問題も発見できなかったので
いろいろ推測を語るんです
推測して語るんです で
シッダールタ王子の粗を調べても調べても調べても微塵もないんです
在家でいた時でも完全たる人格者なんです
悟ってからではないんです
悟ってからも超越した人格者になったんだけど
完璧な人格なんです だからいくら調べても
経典やらあれこれとか見つかりっこはないんです
だから 文献でないならば自分たちで書いてやるぞということで論文を書くんです
赤ちゃんの時 母親が亡くなったので
その寂しさ ショックがあったのではないかと
よく言うんですよ だってお釈迦様生まれて５日目に母親が亡くなったんだから
やっぱりシッダールタ王子は結構寂しかったでしょうと ２８
までますんですね 母親がいないんだから
出家するっていうことで
よくもそんなこと言えたもんだなと思いますよ ２８
で母親がいないんだから
寂しいんだから 俺が出家すると
今まで何やってたんですかね
それだったら お母ちゃん欲しい欲しがるのは１４ぐらいまででしょうに
父親と考えが違っていて
内向的な人ではなかったのかどうか
あの 俗世間の考えを持ってた父親ともちょっと対立があったんじゃないかなとかね
シッダールタがすごい内向的で内向きではなかったのかどうか
証拠ないんですよ でも書いてあります
しかし 文献見ると この父親と息子がぴったし合っていたんです
合って性格的に 父親はいつでも息子
もう万々歳で応援なんです
もう完璧な親バカなんです
スッドーデの王子は もう哲学は決まっています
息子がやることは何であろうとも
これは正しいに決まっている
そういう父親なんです
私の息子がやることは
何であろうともいろいろ言うなよ
正しいに決まってるんだと
それぐらい息子を信頼していたんです
だから対立して 内向的で内向きで出て行ったとか
他の若者と同じく出家をして何かやりたかったのではないかなどなどです
若者だから何か大胆なことをやりたかったんじゃないかなという考えもありますね
それは全部根拠のない嘘なんです
すべて事実無根です 文献から見ると
王子としての生活はどういうものかと
宮殿は３つあったんです
24時間も家来がお世話していたんです
いつでも 大変遊んで生活していたんです
かなり贅沢に遊んでいたんです
出家する気配は全くなかったんです
結局は 天才でしたので
政治家として要する学問をが短時間で修了したんです
これまた楽ちんで もう見るうちに学問全部終わってます
だから先生は 私はあなたに何を教えればいいんですか？ということにになったんですよ
そういうエピソードはもう一応加えたものはありますよ
あるんだけど 南伝北伝
みんな同じことを言ってます
たとえ手を加えたっても
16歳で大変気に入っていた夜叉らお妃と結婚もできたんですよ
16歳なんですよ 結婚までしちゃって
これまた嫌で どうせ政治的な結婚ではなかったんです
王家っていうのは政治的結婚しなくちゃいけないんだからね
ではなくて シッダールタ王子がもう本当に気に入っていたんです
その夜叉夫人お妃が どれほど気に入ったかというと
一応お父さんがしきたりに沿って娘くださいと言うんです
言ったら 娘の父親がね
あの子はね 朝から晩まで遊びばっかしだと
シッダールタ王子が いつ見たっての遊んでいるんだ
あの人に国を投資できると思いますかと
何も勉強したことないでしょうにと
武術とか何もやったことないでしょう
だからうちの息子をアホにあげませんと言ったんだ
はっきりと それで父親がすっごく悲しくなったって
息子のことはもう完璧と思ってるんだからね
息子に言うんです あれはちょっとまずかったと
こう言われたんだと 言ったら
やっぱり本当に立派な息子で
お父さんがすっごく立場が悪くなっていることを知って
あ 大丈夫です 私は何学んでどんな武術できるできているのかと
みんなにデモンストレーションやりますから
準備してくださいと 言うと
息子が乗ってくれたんだから
父親が全部準備して 両国のみんな集めてもらって
シッダールタ王子が自分の腕を見せたんです
何ができるのかと みんなもう大歓声で
もう信じられない あの能力は
それで申し訳ないことを言いましたと
もう謝りながら 夜叉夫人を結婚して結婚を許可したんですよ
だからお釈迦様は頑張ってもらった奥さんでしょうに
だから何も不自由はなかったんです
体力と健康に富んでいて
将軍に必要な武道も習っていて
右に出るものはなかったんです
お釈迦様の場合は 父親にとっては自分の民族を幸福にしてくれる希望の星でした
自分の息子が希望の星
国の希望の星 仏典の説明
残念ですが 現代人が必ずあるはずだと思う
悲しい出来事 失敗 能力不足は何もなかったんです
現代人が出家したんだから
何かブッダに能力不足
悲しい出来事 何か精神的なショックを受けたことあるはずやと探したんだけど
仏典ではないんです 仏典は無始なる過去からブッダになる目的で 10
パーラミタを完成して正覚者になるために計画的に人間として生まれたので
在家生活には初めから興味がなかったことにしています
仏典を見ると お釈迦様の過去の物語全部書いて
これぐらいこれぐらいパーラミタを完成して
またあの33天ではなくて
兜率天にずっと待っていて
インドで家族が揃うまでずっと待っていて
それで神々がもう時間だよと
もう生まれる人間の社会に生まれる時期が出てありますよと
カーローヤンテーマハーヴィーラウッパジャマートグッチヤ
で 偈で語られてありますよ
で これは生まれる時期であると
それでもう菩薩が天国からマーヤ夫人のお腹に入るんです
何のために生まれたかというと
出家してブッダになるためなんです
そのエピソードを書く仏典は
別に珍しくもないという立場なんです
シッダールタ王子出家するのは
だって無始なる過去からその準備で来たんだからね
単なる本番に出てきただけ
という立場をとるんです
それでもお釈迦様が在家の時は大変贅沢をして楽しく生活していたことを
ゴータマ妃は母がいないことを瞬間も感じさせないで
自分の乳を飲ませて大事に育てたことなどを語られるんです
お釈迦様も在家のこと
在家の時は言ってます
私はすごい贅沢でしたと
米はご飯炊く場合はこういう風に選び
選んで選んでいたと 着た服はなんとか国のかしい国の絹
なんとか服しか着ませんでしたとかね
どこへ行ってもみんな傘を傘ではなくて
でっかい白いなんとかですね
パラソルは持っていたんだと
それで自分がね 母親がいないってことを知らなかったと
それぐらいパジャパティ
ゴウタミ妃がね 私の面倒を見ましたと
いうことで お釈迦様 すごい贅沢なんですね
ブッダになってからも
お釈迦様の気に入り地方はカピラバストゥでした
お釈迦様はあれほどインドを歩いたんですけど
カピラバストゥはいいなとか
自分生まれた国はね 気に入りでした
いつでも気持ちはわかりますよ
我々にしたって インド旅をしてカピラバスト入ると
やっぱりこちらに飛行機から来て
ここから出ていけばいいなと思うぐらいなんですからね
インドを通過しないで
本当にすごい環境なんです
注釈書などで釈尊が出家などを考えることもなく生活していると説明する
注釈書には微妙な微妙な矛盾があるんです
お釈迦様は出家するために決まって生まれたんだと言ったっても
またすぐに書くんで 出家する気持ちは全然なかったと
また 父親も我が子が変な考えを起こさないようにいろいろ手を打っていたことも説明する
大胆な天才の息子だから
何考えるかわからないんでね
父親にしたら だから出家なんか考えさせないということに
父親もいろいろ手を打ってやったんだと
しかし神々がこのままではこの王子が出家するわけがないと思い
遊びに行く途中で途中で老いる人
病に陥った人 死体と出家の姿を見せたので
このまま生活に溺れているのではなく
出家しなくてはならないと決めたのだと説明する
長い話は省略しました
で 仏典によると お釈迦様が贅沢三昧で親孝行で生活している
これでは困ります 出家しなきゃ
それで神々もお釈迦様のこと調べたら
こんな遊びふかれている
もう老けているとね 一向に出家しない
何とかしなくちゃと 出家を促す
何とかしなくちゃということで
わざと出来事を起こすんですよ
どういうことかというと
派手に遊びに行く 遊びに行くとボロボロ追い込まれている人が見るんです
見たらびっくりしちゃって
あれ なんでこんななるのかとショックを受ける
それからもうひどく病気になって倒れている人が見て
あら 人間こうなるのかと
それから死体を見る それから穏やかな気持ちでいる出家者を見ると４つ見るんですね
それで この南伝北伝 いろいろちょこちょこ違うところありますよ
この４つも１日で見たという話もある
あるいは１つ見てショックを受けちゃって
それから 1週間  2週間時間かけてから
まあいいわ 忘れちゃったらいいわ
遊びに行きますと また遊びに行ったらまた 2倍目を見たりして
またショックを受けちゃって
また出ない 家出 家から出ないでいて
また３番目  4番目を見たというふうな話もあります １
日に見たという話もあります
この４つは神々が見せてくれたものだともあります
私はそんな話はどうでもいいんです
本当か本当であろうとも
嘘であろうとも なぜならば
一つは読めるんです 出家するつもりはなかったんです
だから 俗世間で考えるように
何か精神的なショックを受けて
財産がなくなって 親に死なれて
女に逃げられて 会社クビになる
クビになって出家したわけじゃないんです
そんなのは一つもありえないんです
一つもないんです あり余った幸福で生きて生活していたんです
どうせ素晴らしい人格者でしたから
もう人間関係であろうか
周りはお釈迦様のためなら死んでもいいやというぐらい
もうみんなものすごいお釈迦様のことをもう可愛がっていたんです
南でも北でも多少違うところがあっても
大体このエピソードは似ているんです
だから そう簡単に嘘やそんなのは作り話だとちょっと言いづらいんですよ
かなり昔から伝わっているストーリーだから
だからお釈迦様に聞きましょう
なんでお釈迦様が出家したんですかと
注釈書ほどドラマチックではないんです
お釈迦様の話は しかし
見事な言葉巧みですから
美しく語られていますよ
すごい感動的になりますが
あれは智慧が現れてくるだけ
ドラマチック的な話ではないんです
あの参考するところは
老 生老病死のことをよく考えていたことを真理に返え
26番目パーサラーシスッタ
一応有名なのであり パリーサナスッタという名前なんです
に記してあります お釈迦様がなんで出家したのかと自分で説かれています
それまた経典の中でも古い
経典の中でも古い方なんです
俗世間的な探求と聖なる探求という 2つのキーワードで出家した状況を語られています
キーワード 2つ探求 俗世間的探求
出世間的 聖なる探求 生まれる性質の人々は
この危機を避けるために生まれる性質のものを探し求める
財産 家族 家畜 家来などなどなど
生 生まれる これって迷惑やと
このままでいようと思ったってね
いろんなことが生まれるんだからね
で 人々っていうのはすごい大変でしょうね
だから皆様もちょっと考えてください
生まれるということはおめでたくはないんです
毎日毎日新しい条件が生まれるんですよ
おめでたくはないんですよ
慣れた生き方は変えなくちゃいけないんです
一番わかりやすい例で言えば
今まで日本は我々は世界一大国だ
経済大国だ 心配することは何一つもないんだというふうに
すごい胸を張っていたんです
1 日にして潰れちゃったんです
全部 何十年ぶりも赤字
何十年ぶり もうもう国債
なんだらかんだらもう全部赤字
赤字 赤字と それ新しい状況生まれたんでしょうね
しかし 政治経済活動をやっている人々は能力がなくて全然手を打たないんですね
政治家にとっては 昔のまんまで流れていった方が懐にお金も入れて気楽でいて
選挙でただで買ってもらって
ずっと 90歳になるまでいられた
いられたいたんですけど
それはできないんですよ
すぐ変わるんです だから毎日いろんなものを
新しい条件が生まれる
そうすると 今までの自分の生き方が崩れるんですよ
だから変化に対応するということも大変です
だから生っていうのはそういうもの
誕生だけではないんです
子供がおぎゃーと生まれたら楽しい
楽しいとみんな思うかもしれませんだけどね
あのおぎゃーと一緒にどれぐらい責任感来るかというと
もうこれから逃げられませんよ
母親にも父親にも これからどれぐらい泣く羽目になるのか
どれぐらい悩み 悩む羽目になるのか
何回学校に呼ばれるのか
わかったもんじゃないんです
それでも子供はうまく成長するかないか
だから 赤ちゃん泣く時は可愛いんだけど
それだけで止めるなよ
それから大変な道があるんです
もう人生変えなくちゃいけない
だからこれって大変ですよ
だから人々は生まれることが嫌で
生が嫌でなんとかします
現状が変わることをなんとかしますと言って同じことやっちゃう
経済世界を見ると同じことでしょう
自然破壊だ 二酸化炭素あれやこれやと言いながら
品物を買え買え買え買えと言っているんです
車は買え買えと  1年一回一台ずつ買い替えなさいよと
そうするとなんとかトヨタ会社が生き延びるんだと
そうすると 500人ぐらい 5000
人ぐらいの人々の首がつなげますよと
それために日本人みんなどれぐらい金使わなくちゃいけないんですかね
おかしいんですよ 一人の面倒を見るためにはそれぐらいお金はかかりませんだけど
車 5万台 10万台買う場合は
まあとにかくそんなことをやってもね
株売買 こうしましょう
ああしましょう 同じことですけど
また潰れますよ と言って
まだ潰れたまんまですけど
それで仏様が言うのは
物事は生まれる で 面倒くさい
これは面倒くさいと思って
人々はもっとたくさんそこだけ生まれるものを探しましょうと
だから 例えば家畜動物をあるとどうなるんですかね
大変です 財産 妻子などなどを探し求めるんだと
早く来ます 老いることを嫌で老いるものを探し求める
老いることは嫌なんですよ
だから老いないために老いるものを預けるんです
集めるんです 意味がある
だからこれは私は糖尿病だからケーキしか食べませんよということと同じなんです
それでなんであんた糖尿病になったの？だって昔からケーキばっかり食っていたんだと
だからもう糖尿病は嫌だと
もしかすると目が見えなくなるかもしれませんと
だから私はケーキしか食べないことにしましたと
バカでしょうに あまりにもおかしいでしょうね
人間それやってるんだと
老いることは嫌で 老いないために老いるものを集めてもらう
例えば女性の方々は年取るのは嫌でしょうね
しかし 旦那が欲しい 子供も欲しいでしょ
旦那に子供に囲まれて生活したいでしょうに 3
倍スピード早くなりますよ
年取るスピードは あれに関わると子供が病気になると寝ないで苦労しなくちゃいけないし
だからそれでは老いが早めに早めるだけなんです
だから財産などなどはそういうものであると
病に陥り陥りたくない人は
病に陥るものは探し求める
死にたくない人は死すべきものばかりを探し求める
財産 家族などなどです
悩み苦しみが嫌で 悩み苦しみに陥るものを探し求める
例えば 誰かに別れてもう振られちゃって悲しいんでしょ
一生懸命探す もう一人好きな人を探し
選びましょうと また同じことですけど
促進 そういうことでしょう
例えば 若い人がもう付き合ってる人に振られると落ち込んじゃうでしょ
みんな何言います？何言います？落ち込んでる人どうやって慰める？こんな一人二人に振られたってもね
いくらでもいますよと
頑張ってくださいと わかるでしょ？どれほどアホかと
私のところにもそうやって男の子がね
すごい落ち込んできたんだから
私はどうやって慰めたかというと
あ そう 一回初めてでしょ
あんたにとっては何だこりゃ
あとあと 10 回ぐらい同じ羽目に遭わないと
またまた人を探して またまた振られて
またこのきつい気持ちになって 10
回ぐらい会わなきゃダメですよ
帰ってくださいと それが答えでしょうに
まああんた あの人ではなくて
いい人を見つけてくださいと
それじゃないんです 私はもっとこの苦しみを味わいなさいと
だから私のところに一回で解決ですからね
私は言ったのはそんなことはね
あんたまだまだ人間になってないんだと
ただ形だけで 性格的にはもうガッタガタの人間でしょうにと
資格はないんだと もう一人の面倒を見る
だからこのあなたはもう一人前のしっかりした人になるまでは
もうフラれるわフラれるきりがないんだよと
そこは事実であって 客観的な答えであって
それを理解すれば その子は別にしっかり道を切り開くんです
心が汚れるのは嫌で 心が汚れるものを探し求める
人間というのは心が汚れるのは嫌なんですよ
誰でも しかし 金が欲しい
付き合うための友達が欲しいと心がむちゃくちゃ汚れるんですよ
結局は これは俗世間的探求です
ここで誰の生きる生きる目的でも
財産 妻子 家畜など必死で得る生き方を説明しているんですね
なんか文章おかしい それからお釈迦様はざーっと長い長い経典ですよ
人の目的っていうのは
財産を得ること 家族がいること
子供がいること 有名になること
金銀宝石があること で
田んぼを畑いっぱいあること
家畜 家畜動物がいっぱいいること
昔話ですからね それから召使たちがいっぱいいることなんですね
みんな必死でそればっかり探してますよ
あなた何の目的やけど
私は死にたくない 長生きしたい
病気になりたくない 何か問題起きたら大変だからと
あんなものがあると問題起こるでしょうに
問題が起きたら大変というのは
小 年取りたくないんだから
立派な牛たくさん買って
最高級の乳製品を食べているとかね
あんなものを食べちゃうと早くも年取ります
病気になります 結局は
だから 老病死は嫌で 老老病死になるものを探しているんだと
だから これは世間の道である
話にならない道をやっているんです
それで 4つじゃないんです
お釈迦様が神々の話では 4つ見たんですね
あの病人と老人と死体と出家
しかし お釈迦様ご自分あれは仏典です
誰か書いたものです 仏教経典というのはお釈迦様が語ったものです
お釈迦様ご自分で言うのは 5つの項目なんです
小老 病 死 4つ それから悩み
苦しみ それから心の汚れ
サンキリサダンマという 5番目
お釈迦様は項目 5つ考えていたんです
6つや  6つですね  6です
6つを項目6つを考えていたんです
それで世間もこの項目6つは嫌なんです
老病死と心が汚れることと悩み
苦しみが嫌なんです では
私は老病死に関わるものを全部集めてもらいますと
それが私の人生の目的にするんだと
なんだこれと それなんです
それで自動的に出家の世界でしょ
最近の生き方って何なのかと
ケーキ食べて糖尿病になったんだから
ケーキだけ食べますよという生き方ではないかと
だったらその生き方するもんじゃないんです
しかし これでは答えにならない
解決にならないという意味を持つ言葉なんです
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
これ言ってないんです
間接的に提案する こんなのはアホくてもう見ていられないんだと
再起の生き方は これ言ってないんだよ
だから私がいいだけで
品のない言葉は全部私の
お釈迦様はとっても品格のある言葉で
こういう風に生きているのですと
次に聖なる探求 生まれる性質の人は不称
超越した安穏 涅槃という境地を探し求めるんだと
だから生が苦だから 嫌だから
大変だから 不称の境地がないのかと
何も現れてない 現れない境地がないのか
この俗世間の生き方 超越した境地がないのか
安穏の境地がないのか
涅槃という安穏な境地がないのかと探すんだよと
これが聖なる探求です
老い 病 死 悩み 汚れに対しても同じ説明をします
いわゆる老いの性質のを見て
不老の超越した安穏解脱の境地を探し求めるんだと
病に対して不病 無病の超越した境地を探しますと
死に対して不死なる超越した安穏の境地を探し求めるんだと
だから サイケでいるんじゃなくて
これを乗り越えて 何とかないんでしょうかと
別な生き方ないのかと探すんです
それが仏教の出家なんです
夜逃げじゃないんです
仏典では真夜中 密かに宮殿を出て出家したのだと書いてはあるが
この古い経典では 両親が涙を流しながら泣いているにも関わらず
髪の毛と髭を剃って出家したのだとお釈迦様が説かれているんです
仏典と経典はそこでちょっと違うんですね
インドでも彫刻なんかを見る時でも面白いことあるんですよ
お釈迦様が真夜中 誰にも言わないでこそっと出家しますと
そうすると厳しい警備なんですね
お釈迦様の周りは そこでカンタカという馬に乗って行ったんだと
あのチャンナという馬の扱い人と一緒に出て行ったと
お釈迦様もチャンナのことを言ってるんだから
なんか関係あったと思いますけど
そうすると馬がパカパカと出ていくと
みんなもう家来の警備の人々
目が覚めるでしょう そうすると四天王の神が
4人が馬が足を入れる入れるたびに自分も手をクッションに入れてあげたと
それで音が出ないようにと
あの神 4人が大変ですよ
あの このくだらない神々よりは私は
は 観音像の前にはろうそくも何も立てませんだけど
この四天王のあれやったらろうそく一本立てます
まあ線香 1本はやっぱり仏典に出てくるし
結構苦労しましたからね
で それから門になってくると
門のいる神々は門を開けてくれたと
そこでマーラが開けて
あなたどこに行くのかと
迷なかと あと 1週間待ちなさいよと
1週間であなたはもう偉大なる王になるんだよと
天霊王になるんだよと
世界支配することできますよと
それでお釈迦様 お釈迦様はどけどけと言って出て行ったんですという話は仏典にありまして
しかし この経典ではお釈迦様
お父さんもお母さんも泣いていたんだよと
出家するときは ずっと
お母さんというのはゴータミ妃のことなんです
だから こっそり逃げたわけじゃないんです
父親はよく理解していたんですよ
この子は偉大なる人だから
邪魔するものではない
すごい目的で今探求に出ていこうとしているんだと
本当は応援して 何て言いますか
見送りしなくちゃいけないんだけど
そんなこと言ったっても
父親には我慢できない
だから泣いていたんです
アカマカーンマとピトゥンなんルダンターナ
というススススカーラケーソダハーロ様のバットよ
そういうふうにいろいろダラダラダラダラと文章ありますけど
昔は暗記していました
今忘れました 体力に溢れた若者であったにもかかわらず
出家したのですと強調するんです
わざわざと強調するんです
体力もあった 髪の毛が白い若者であったと
親がもうすごく嫌で泣いていたんだと
え？黒いですか？あ 黒い
すいません 私のことですか
髪の毛も黒くて すごい若い時は
出家しましたと だから決して俗世間考える出家じゃないんですよ
人間の生き方を観察したんです
社会人の生き方を観察したんです
すると バカくてあまりにもバカバカらしくて見ていられないんですね
矛盾だらけ それだったら天才で生まれた悪運もありますから
みんなに道を切り開いてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから人類にいつでも大胆なことを提案するのは天才でしょう
だからお釈迦様には責任があったんです
この人々はこのまま苦しみだけやと
心が汚れるばっかりやと
嫌なのに 苦しみは嫌なのに苦しむだけやと
誰も見つかりっこない
この道は みんなバカなことをやっている
同じことをやっている
じゃあ私は世間の生き方と違った生き方をして探してますということで出家したんです
お釈迦様の出家は夜逃げではないのです
開拓者 発見者 探求者の道なんです
開拓者 発見者は何か大胆なことをしなきゃ開拓発見できないでしょうに
誰にもできなかったことに
知らなかったことに挑戦する挑戦者の道なんです
チャレンジャーなんです
偉大なる天才が その他の人々にできないできないことを自分でやらなくてはならないと思って選んだ道なんです
自分が偉大なる天才者に生まれたんです
だから 普通の人々のできないことをやらなくてはいけないんですよ
父親も嫌なのに泣きながら偉大なる息子の勇気のいる挑戦を見守っていたんです
だから あの父親っていうのは
思い出すと私の目には涙が来るんですよ
どれほど立派な父親かというと
息子は完全に信頼して
息子はすごいことをやるに違いありませんと
しかし 家ですることは
こんなに可愛い息子がね
いなくなることを我慢できない
でもこらえるんですよ
こらえられなくて泣くんです
それでもお釈迦様が父親が泣いているんだからやめましたという
この腰抜けじゃないんです
それでお釈迦様が後で出ます
それからの修行中 悟りに目的に達したか否かと情報収集していたんです
スッドーダナ王様も黙っていなかったんです
あちこち諜報員を送ったんです
シッダ当時には気づかない
気づかれないように どういうことかというと
自分の息子は決めたらやるんだと
何かやろうとしたら成功させるんだと
だから父親はそれ知りたいんです
だからいろんな師匠たちを訪ねていくと
スッドーダナ王子にも報告が入るんです
今あちらにいるんだ 今あちらにいるんだとか
そういうことで 家は嫌で逃げたというね
話はあまりにもですよ
シッダブッダに対して言うのは
俗世間の出家じゃないんです
老病死は絶対嫌です それを避けられるなら何でもやります
これは誰の気持ちでもあります
しかし 金儲けに 家族に
家族を養うことに精一杯頑張るんです
結局は あっけなく病んで老いて死ぬ
得たものをすべて置いていく
人々は生老病死は絶対嫌なのに
何もやってないんです
家族を養うことに精一杯です
それで財産を得ますけど
すべて置いてあっけなく消えてしまいます
あの世には何も持っていかないでしょ
大失敗の人生です だから俗世間の人生は
大失敗の人生なんです
逆になるんです 今まで私は俗世間の立場で説明していたでしょ
成功者たちと成功者たちは在家で失敗者
負け犬が出家と 本当は仏教の出家は大違います
仏教から見れば 在家生活する人々は大失敗の人生を歩んでいます
すべて捨てて あっけなく死ぬんです
何もないんです 何のために苦労しているのかと
だから大勝利者の道なんです
必ず勝利の道が仏教の出家なんです
清らかな穏やかな心でいたいのに
心が汚れる一方の道です
在家の道は 在家では心は汚れるは汚れるはきりがなく汚れるは
ただ黙っていても汚れますよ
いい加減な無知な矛盾で悪循環の生き方を破る道が仏教の出家なんです
この在家に在家のいい加減な無知な矛盾で
それから悪循環に入っていることを破る道
これは普通の人が気楽に聞いても答えられないんですよ
何でお釈迦様が出家したんですかと
理解できる能力ないんです
あれ すごいことなんです
生命って何なのかと知り尽くした上で取った態度なんです
人間が苦しみは嫌で苦しみを得る
苦しみは嫌で苦しみを探す
しかし気づかない それが上から見たブッダ
お釈迦様はシッダールタ王子に見えるんですよ
天才でしたから それで取った大胆な態度なんです
だからインドにいた出家者の真似したわけじゃないんです
誰の真似も だからお釈迦様はクタクタ非難していますから
インドの出家をクタクタ非難しているんです
今日は時間ないんだから
こういう経典を紹介できませんだけど
突然出家したわけではなく
天才として人の生き方を長年観察した上で
皆のためにも解決策を見つからなくてはと思ってとった態度なんです
あの神々に突然何か見せちゃって
見せられて あ 出家する
そんないい加減なことを決めるじゃないんです
よく観察していたんです
お釈迦様は 再起の時は人生って何なのかと
それで取った態度なんです
自分が天才的能力を持っていたんだから
皆のために何とかしなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば地震が起きて 何か洞窟みたいなところで
みんなもうもう囲まれてしまったと
追い込まれてしまったと
逃げられないんだと そちらにすごい体力のある巨人がいるとしましょう
それでその人の責任ですよ
洞窟を開けて 険しい山を一人一人背負って下ろして
安全な場所に連れて行くのは
船が遭難したらキャプテンの仕事なんですよ
その人は海のプロなんです
船に乗ってる人々はみんな助けてあげてから
自分が救命ボートに乗ると最後に
だから生命の かけがえのない
もうこの上もない天才能力を持って生まれたんだから
ブッダの責任というのは
大変です それを果たしたんです
やることはやるんです
お釈迦様はずっと説法を聞いたりすると
お釈迦様の経典を読んだりすると
お釈迦様は弟子たちを叱ったりする時も見ると
腰肉はいかに嫌かと ブッダが
決めたことやりなさいと
ある日 お釈迦様に質問されたんですよ
人はどこまで努力するべきか
努力するべきなのかと
人はどこまで努力するべきなのかという偈ですけど
答えは結果が出るまでである
すごい短い文章ですけど
いかに正しい言葉かというと
結果が出るが出るまで
わやめてポリソヤワアッタッサニッパダ
自分の目的に達するまで努力するんだよと
だから仏教の出家は逃げじゃないんです
逆です 生きることは苦であり
空しいものであると知っていたのです
お釈迦様は しかし 皆に何か別な道
別な生き方があるのではないかと発見できないことに
生命に 無知に対して哀れみを持って出家なさったんです
みんなみんななんとなく知ってますよ
生きることは意味がないんだと
だってみんな知らないでしょ？何のために生きているのかと
ないんだから空しいんです
なのに解決策は持ってない
悪循環でぐるぐるぐる回るんであって
何もできない あの買ってるリスみたいですね
なんとか回転するあれで回転するだけで
どこにも行ったことになってないんです
それでお釈迦様が憐れみを持っていたんです
一切の生命に対して 私がこの道を発見しなくちゃいけないんだと
出家後 その道を発見した人はいるのかと探したのです
それから出家して いわゆる宮殿を出て
誰かインドでいるのかと
この道を発見した人がいたならば
もう楽ちんだからね その人に教えてもらっちゃえば
すごい素直ですよ お釈迦様は科学者なんですよ
新しいものを発見するといい加減なことをしたっても
どこかの研究所で発見しているのは意味がないでしょうに
そのどこかの研究所で発見しているならば
そのレポートを取って読むしかないんです
だからまず探したんです
先生たちを それは善とは何かと探し求めて
師匠を訪ねて歩いたエピソードに語られてあります
同じ経典に書いてあります
私は善とは何かと探し求めて先生たちを訪ねましたと
この善とは何かということはすごい意味深い言葉で
人が歩むべき道は何なのかなんです
我々は歩むべき正しい道は何なのかと
金儲けじゃないんです
別な道があるんです それを探したんです
あとで あ あの前途中でやめた経典がまた来るんです
ラッタパーラ尊者がコーラヴィ王に答える
ウパニーヤティローコアッドー
世界生命は置いていくもの
常住できない 常住ではない
ラッタパーラ長老はあの王様に言うんで
あんて あんたなんで出家したのかと聞いたら
あのね 王様 私にはお釈迦様が教えた言葉があります
それ聞いて出家しましたと
その言葉ですよ 一つは
この世は生命はずっと無常で変化するんだと
常住ということはありない
ないんだと いくら頑張っても変化するんだから
虚しいんです アターノーローコワナヴィッセル
この世 命は頼りにならない
自由にならない 生きるということは全然自由にならないんです
実際にならないんです
アッサコーローコサッバンパハヤガミニヤン
この世で何も自分のものにはならない
何やってるのか 我々は
もう獲得するはするは得るは貯めるは貯めるは貯めるは
いくら貯めても あの塵一つも自分のものにならないんです
たった塵一つ すべて捨てて去らなくてはいけないんです
ウーノーローコアティトタンナーダース
この世はいつも満たされないんです
我々の心はいつだっても満たされてないんです
渇愛の奴隷なんです 釈尊に説かれたこの四つのことを考えて
シャッカターリ尊者が出家のったんです
それでこの四行の説明はものの見事なんです
王様にわからなかったんです
王様がカッタバーラさん
この短く言ってもわかりませんだから説明してくださいと
それでそういうものの見事に説明したんです
はい それ時間ないんだから飛ばします
な